de bouche à oreille nouveau numéro on va
parler du pata negra le pata negra
pattes noires en fait c'est un cochon
doit c'est un cochon noir en fait il ya
deux sortes de cochon avec dès qu'elle
en fait de la charcuterie une très bonne
chose on disait et on est toujours que
dans le cochon tout est bon et bien le
cochon pata negra ces taxes sont
espagnols mais en réalité ce sont les
romains qui ont emporté le cochon noir
en espagne en passant par la corse ce
qu'il a construit son dancing with des
cochons noirs en corse alors les
espagnols qui sont des gens qui ont le
sens du marketing mais aussi le sens de
la qualité ont réussi à faire avec des
cochons noirs un produit en charcuterie
extraordinaire magnifique mais la
particularité patrice c'est que
contrairement aux cochons blanc les
charcuteries qui sont faites avec des
cochons noirs attention uniquement ceux
qu'on appelle les pure bel iota c'est à
dire les cochons y sont nourris au gland
le budget à cette blanche exactement en
espagnol bbe iota ça veut dire globe et
alors ce qui est extraordinaire patrie
c'est que pour ses cochons qui sont très
haut de gamme la particularité c'est que
les quatre derniers mois de leur
existence ils sont gavés aux glands
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
particularité et pourquoi est ce que ce
cette charcuterie est bonne pour la
santé et bien tout d'abord parce que les
glands ont les mêmes particularités
organoleptiques que les olives l'huile
d'olive exactement donc en réalité quand
fabrice toi voilà vous avez parfaitement
compris et donc les cochons qui sont
élevées au gland génère dans leurs
graisses ce qu'on appelle du bon gras
voilà et est-ce que c'est pas
extraordinaire bon cholestérol et 10,6
en se disant c'est une beau c'est le
rêve de tous les gourmands voilà c'est
génial
cauchon vive le gland
l'espace d'un mois il faudrait bien leur
travail n'oublions pas qu'il ya du très
bon jambon de bayonne ainsi on rit oui
mais pas convaincu pas qu'à bayonne la
france entière c'est parce que de la
base
oui alors justement à bayonne il ya
aussi des jambes ont affiné comme ça il
essayera et plus qui sont d'excellente
qualité bon il sauf qu'en ce moment on a
un peu le vent en poupe à l'appui on
laisse pas dit le pata negra mais il ya
aussi des cochons noirs qui sont en
train de remonter vers le pays basque
celui droit merci infiniment je n'ai
comme avec à bientôt patrice